I remember seeing when you did the the
Yogi Bear audition right that was yeah
yeah yeah I think and I was so jealous I
remember seeing like man this guy he
just so it's for Allison Jones I think
he did it for was that right yeah
totally but that because you did a
special audition right you did a special
audition where this is what I heard this
is just from okay this guy found a bear
somewhere and got to go win and did a
special edition next to a very dangerous
bear
yeah and got a really good take and
submitted the and submitted that as the
audition and said you should be a part
of this so the truth is I went and I
audition because I thought it would be
funny to be in Yogi Bear 3d mm-hmm
because it would be a funny stand-up
credit right mm-hm
and it would just be silly to do that
and I'm kind of on a Ferris was gonna be
in and I was like oh my god that would
be amazing
because she's like one of my comedy
idols and then I went and I did the
audition with Allison Jones it went well
and then I went and I bought a Ranger
hat as a joke and I went in and I I went
in and I was like hey I just wanted to
look Lagos alright I brought my own
Ranger hat and I was just wondering if I
could use it I don't have to but it was
$19.99 and you know I can't return it I
can exchange it for something else but I
bought it for the audition and they were
kind of like yeah that's fine man I was
like great there and I put the I put on
the Hat and they say your name and slate
you know the poor kid in the casting
system that's got the camera say her
name in slate my joke with that is I'm
always like TJ Miller auditioning for
the role of Yogi Berra 3d I'm 6 foot 3
but when I act I crouch so I'm 6 foot 2
and then they're like ok we're ready and
then I go I'm sorry can I just stop you
guys real quick and there's poor casting
Society
you something how much about how much
head room do I have because I'm gonna be
doing a lot of hat work so if you can
give me sort of enough so think of it
less is head room more hat room so how
much Hat room do I have and this kids
like I mean I don't know like about this
I was like yeah but I can't that's
smaller to me than it is to you because
you're far away so just tell me when to
stop
and I was like and he's like he's like
no no stop before there I was like can
you get can you give me this what about
here
okay cuz I'm gonna be doing kind of like
and kind of that sort of stuff so do I
have room to do that in this kids like
yeah sure they're already cracked so now
you've already got a lot of humor going
before the auditions already yeah that's
a key Brody has got so then Alison
texted me actually after the audition
she was like you know there you're their
first choice and I think this is your
gonna get good news tomorrow and I was
like tell them that I want to submit
supplemental materials to give them a
better idea of what I would do with the
part she was like I don't think you need
to and I was like yeah but I have this
great idea so that I did I when I rented
a bear at the Hollywood animals oh
really I feel like and then I made it
send it to them and you have it was a
joke the whole thing is right I get it
but still as a resident as somebody that
audition stuff that would feel like
sucked to a regular person yeah for the
full lobe yeah that feeling because
you're like already have like I'm just
be like I'm gonna I'm just 3/4 low back
guys and so I I sent them this audition
because you got to think about if I've
already gotten it and then I make a
funny video like that's not gonna hurt
the situation so I sent it and they
watched it I thought it's so funny and
they sent all the way up to alan horne
who was the head of the studio at the
time jewish guy or not he I'm not sure
but I think I met him he warned he he
goes yeah he's been I think he's the
head of he was the head of Warner
Brothers and now he's the head of he's
involved in Disney somehow and he he
never laughs at anything and he watched
this good and he didn't laugh but he was
like we should we should hire this kid
he's really really funny and
I said well yeah he was he was our first
choice so I did that movie yeah 2010 and
that's the film that right afterwards my
actually while I was in the film my
brain hemorrhage just slightly [ __ ] yeah
and I started to go actually insane like
clinically insane because there was just
too much blood in my brain and then when
I came back afterwards I was in like a
really crazy state and I that's when I
had the seizures plural and went to the
hospital they're like we need to operate
on your back bring it all around full
circle
that's an amazing order Logan it
coast-to-coast
you know it's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one